[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
dans le 7-8 loisirs vos idées sorties
dans le département on commence au tout
avec le sommaire de ce numéro
ce samedi la fête va battre son plein
sur le parvis de l'hôtel de ville de
magny les hameaux
cette année la thématique le futur
thérèse mallem adjointe au maire en
charge de la communication nous parlera
du programme de la peinture au bitume
c'est une exposition proposée par huile
en cours
l'artiste danielle proulx venant
présente ses oeuvres jusqu'à fin janvier
découverte dans ce magazine
enfin dans notre rendez-vous junior
mélanie ok nous apprendre à réaliser sa
propre couronne de noël
un atelier décoration à faire en famille
pour les fêtes et on commence tout
d'abord par un film avec omar sy demain
tout commence et dans les salles
obscures depuis ce mercredi 7 décembre
pour assurer la promotion l'équipe du
film était présente à l'ugc de saint
quentin en yvelines afin de faire un
débat avec le public
michael et minéraux en a profité pour
rencontrer les acteurs omar sy et ilaria
gloria colston il nous en donner leurs
impressions
alors ce scénario du coup il vous a plu
tout de suite dès que vous l'avez lu
mais très drôle tout de suite tout de
suite tout pour faire tous les éléments
pour une très bonne comédie même temps
les éléments pour avoir un bon vélo un
beau un bon moyen de passer de l'un à
l'autre comme ça et après et après avec
avec la mise en scène de d'hugo pour
avoir le bon équilibre entre les deux je
crois que c'était ça qu'il fallait
heureusement qu'on a eu le goût pour
promettre 100 places et je crois qu'on a
un film qui a un bon équilibre de tout
ça en fait la finmul qui mêle à la fois
le rire et l'émotion
le centre alfred de vigny de
voisins-le-bretonneux mais un artiste
vit sinois à l'honneur jusqu'au 16
décembre
le public est invité à découvrir les
oeuvres de jean claude giraud c'est la
première expression
de ce peintre autodidacte portraits
animaux paysages une quarantaine de ses
tableaux orne les murs on écoute un mot
de l'artiste j'ai commencé dans les
années 2000 8,9 à faire du dessin et
samassa m'a branché jeunes ont commencé
par par dessin au crayon bien la
sanguine puis au pastel et finalement je
suis arrivé à faire de l'huile un
domaine qui est un peu plus ma maison
disons très hétéroclite
j le principal but étant de faire
plaisir
donc chaque fois qu'on me demande
quelque chose j'essaye de contenter
celui qui me le demandent
samedi magny les hameaux mais son parvis
en fait comme chaque année à cette
période le parvis de l'hôtel de ville
est dédié à différentes animations
spectacles de rue et ateliers thérèse
mallem chargé de communication à la
mairie de magny les hameaux nous a
rejoint bonjour thérèse bonjour l'âme
lambert alors du coup c'est une nouvelle
édition qui débute demain dès 15 heures
et sous la thématique du futur nouvelle
édition
ça fait quand même deux plus de douze
ans que cet événement existe mais c'est
toujours un plaisir pour les manies quoi
et toutes les personnes qui veulent se
joindre à nous pour participer à cet
événement très attendu et donc alors le
futur lancement on disait pourquoi cette
thématique
qu'est ce qui est plus important que le
futur mais bon c'est vrai que c'est une
thématique a été choisie collégialement
le passé restera le passé nous vivre au
présent et nous préparons le futur donc
c'est vrai que ce sont les enfants qui
font l'avenir et c'est pour ça que nous
avons souhaité faire participer les
enfants à la création de leur futur
alors du coup de canne manière à ce que
souhaitaient les faire participer il ya
différentes animations qui sont
proposées tout l'après midi exactement
donc principalement ça va être création
de ma ville ma vie future
donc effectivement c'est eux c'est
l'avenir c'est les enfants
donc ils ont la chance de participer à
des animations des ateliers de création
dont on va voir comment on construit nos
villes il ya d'autres ateliers également
atelier cuisine
moléculaire et qui est cité en
construction d'un robot est ce que vous
nous en dire un peu plus ce qu'est ce
que c'est que la cuisine moléculaire par
exemple alors cuisine moléculaire ça
serait voir ce que pourraient prendre
les astronautes dans leur refuser par
exemple comment comment manger des
collations de costumes également en fera
je voudrais pas tout vous dire ça mais
surprise regardons ailleurs gardé les
surprises donc c'est vrai qu'on
reconnaît on sait des choses mais si on
dit tout alors on voudrait que les
enfants aient envie de venir et puis se
voir justement ce qu'est tous et toutes
ces choses qui sont le futur a donc on
dévoilera pas tous les secrets non
rendra quand même peut-être un petit
hommage aux différentes aux associations
qui anime ces ateliers lors qu'elles
sont elles ces associations est ce que
vous pouvez nous les présente alors une
association qui quand même toujours
présente à manier un mot c'est quand
même les amis des staline et c'est quand
même cette association qui travaille des
heures des heures pour préparer le
goûter qui sera distribuée cet après
midi là où on sait que déjà que ce matin
y avait plus de 1000 part de gâteau qui
avaient été confectionnés 400 crêpes
barbe à papa qui seront distribués aussi
donc c'est toujours beaucoup de travail
et beaucoup de plaisir parce qu'il ya
une joie partagée tout le monde
maisons se sont sacrés chiffres effet
science fait beaucoup de diatribes il y
en aura du coup pour tous les goûts pour
tous les âges où tous les âges
distribution de chocolats chauds et vin
chaud pour les adultes
et puis depuis deux ans les amis
l'estaminet distribue aussi de la soupe
pour une dégustation de soupe
voilà bon ça c'est son cette association
vous avez aussi l'association fab lab
qui va faire son imprimante 3d donc y
aura des démonstrations et comment
fonctionne une imprimante 3d donc ça va
être très intéressant ça se fera à
raison de l'enseignement environnement
maison des sciences et le développement
durable voilà des ateliers plusieurs
lieux on leur précise effectivement le
gros des animations ça sur le parvis sur
l'argile
il accueillait également l'ancienne
maison de l'environnement et la salle du
conseil il ya donc les séances
maquillage
comment dire création de costumes 6 à ce
niveau là exactement 1 création des
costumes et donc du coup un petit mot
sur cette thématique le futur mobiliser
c'est vraiment pour essayer de préparer
l'avenir vous l'avez évoqué justement
avec les imprimantes 3d c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'important à sensibiliser
bien sûr je pense je pense que c'est
très important
on fait tellement de choses enfin bon
moi je ne sais pas une spécialiste de
tout ce qui est une nouvelle technologie
et pourtant je fais tout pour été aussi
il est intéressé mais c'est les enfants
qui doivent comprendre que le monde
change le monde change et ça ça passe
par justement les nouvelles imprimantes
et tout ce qu'on peut créer pour le
futur alors on va dire oui sur la le
spectacle de fin de spectacle de clôture
de cette journée c'est google d'ours
alors qu'est ce que c'est que ce
spectacle alors il ya plusieurs temps
forts à pendant ses paris en fait donc
est le spectacle de fin donc pas la
compagnie remue ménage donc c'est un
spectacle d'imitation de deux
personnages d'animaux ça fera très joli
bon ça c'est surtout le soir donc on va
partir de 17h15
probablement il y aura peut-être une
représentation à 15h15 mais bon comme
c'est la journée sefra différents il
faut vraiment pas louper le spectacle du
soir
plus le tirage et c'est darty 6 à 18
heures de clôture le cac clôture le
paris en fait et le passage du père noël
à ne pas manquer évidemment avant un
mois qu'il soit trop occupé avec le
temps il y aura aussi une petite
surprise que les enfants attendent qu'on
essaie de faire est de maintenir au fil
des années super merci beaucoup thérèse
à même d'être venu merci à vous le
rappel du coup un parvis en fête a lieu
samedi 10 décembre dès 15h sur le parvis
de l'hôtel de ville de magny les hameaux
pour un voyage vers le futur et on prend
maintenant la direction de guyancourt et
plus exactement de l'hôtel de ville
le peintre daniel convenant à habiter la
ville pendant plusieurs années et
présente ses nouveaux travaux de la
peinture au bitume sur toile découverte
dans ce reportage
un noir chaud et une multitude de
teintes le bitume et le moyen
d'expression de daniel convenant après
avoir découvert ce matériau en 2008
l'artiste peintre en a fait sa marque de
fabrique
ça représente le temps je veux c'est le
but il savait du pétrole qui lui-même ne
garder la composition des matériaux
comme le bois et tout ça est donc pour
moi c'est ça représente le temps je
passe par des périodes plus ou moins
longues de réfection et tout ça jusqu'au
jour où j'ai envie de te est donc le
premier geste cgb d'un seul coup et pour
moi c'est une évidence au coeur de ses
créations la figure de l'arbre son
écorce et ses noeuds par ses tableaux
daniel convenant cherche à exprimer ses
émotions sur le temps la vie et la
mémoire
un art intimement lié son avc en 1993
qui l'a plongé dans le coma pour moi
larmes c'était ma la construction donc
je suis rentré dans le tronc de l'arbre
pourquoi le trompe tout simplement va se
passer c'est entre l'ombre à lui l'est
les racines et le feuillage d'allumer la
lumière donc c'était le trait du nord
centrale et de tout ce le fait à chaque
fois c'est une toile
c'est une partie de moi même c'est un
instant de ma vie donc c'est pour ça
c'est la candidate buteau c'est comme le
bitume
c'est ma route daniel convenant revient
à guyancourt après y avoir exposé il ya
19 ans ses oeuvres sont à découvrir
jusqu'au 28 janvier en août
elles partiront pour le centre national
des arts de tokyo après les calendriers
de l'avent une nouvelle chronique junior
de saison le mois de décembre rime avec
décorations de noël et mélanie poker va
nous apprendre à réaliser sa propre
couronne la fameuse couronne qu'on peut
trouver sur les portes d'entrée et on
peut en trouver des tout fait bien sûr
dans les commerces sur les marchés comme
celle que d link unique on va voir à
l'image elle les crée elle même elle les
propose sur le marché de versailles mais
bien sûr on peut faire sa propre
couronne première étape ont choisi la
couronne en elle même il faut avoir une
base en panne on peut en trouver dans le
commerce entre 2 et 5 euros et choisir
les branches de sapin pour la forme et
hélène nous donne quelques conseils
je prends les plus beaux de manière
qu'ils soient réguliers
après voilà si on va dire c'est qu'ils
soient bien vert que le sapin soit bien
vert qui soit pas sec
le nordmann c'est celui qui perd pas ses
épines d'épicéa est très jolie il sent
mais celui-là perdra plus vite de ses
épines
ensuite on monte la couronne en
enroulant les branches de sapin autour
de la paille pour le faire tenir il faut
du fil de fer de laiton ou du fil de
pêche alors c'est quand même un peu
technique femmes à faire pour les
enfants alors d'habitude je propose des
activités qui peuvent se faire tout seul
là clairement la couronne c'est en
famille un adulte doit toujours
surveiller mais quand on voit le
résultat sincèrement je pense que ça
vaut le coup on peut aussi acheter la
base de toutes faites ou même prendre
une base en osier une fois la couronne
fait on passe au plus sympa la découvre
alors on choisit des petits éléments ce
qu'on veut des petites décorations qu'on
peut trouver dans les magasins
d'ateliers créatifs avec hélène on est
parti sur une ambiance plutôt rouge et
vert alors un ruban pour faire tenir la
couronne un bonhomme de neige qu'on voit
à l'écran des petites boules de noël des
petits cadeaux et des bâtonnets de
cannelle alors c'est une décoration
qu'on peut aussi réaliser
élément naturel qu'on peut trouver dans
la nature des feuilles d'arbres des
pommes de pin mais alors pour faire
tenir tout ça comment est ce qu'on fait
alors c'est là que la présence de
l'adulte est indispensable très vite
comprendre pourquoi parce qu'il faut
utiliser un pistolet à colle et je ne
sais pas que je ne sais pas vous camille
mais si vous en avez déjà utilisé un oui
c'est très il faut faire très attention
parce que ça brûle donc il faut être
très vigilant
voilà mais bon on sait quand même
plaisir alors on colle comme on souhaite
un petit peu de colle sur chacun des
éléments on attend quelques secondes
pour être sûr que ça accroche bien pour
le podium pour le bonhomme de neige une
autre technique il faut mettre une
petite pique dessus le bâton on le
plante dans la couronne
mais comme chaque activité une seule
consigne camille je pense que vous la
connaissez c'est de s'amuser tout à fait
mes résultats étaient paisibles
merci beaucoup mais la lie donc avis aux
amateurs vous pouvez vous lancer sans
inquiétude avec cette jolie couronne à
réaliser facilement se limite votre
créativité et on passe maintenant à
notre agenda voici les prochains rendez
vous à ne pas manquer jeudi 15 décembre
l'association lecture et dialogues
organise une rencontre avec natacha
henry l'écrivain historienne parlera de
son dernier livre sur sa vente maric
marie curie et brahmia luz cas demain
après-midi l'académie home kido propose
un cours de yoga gratuit animé par le
fondateur du dialogue à un yoga lent et
perceptif l'occasion de découvrir cette
technique
l'événement est accessible à tous et
pour les mélomanes le coeur viva voce
organise son concert de noël ce dimanche
à guyancourt
sous la direction de catherine lautier
les 50 choristes reprendront les oeuvres
de mozart vivaldi ou encore bizet et on
se quitte sur un extrait justement du
requiem de mozart interprété par le
choeur viva voce
je veux retrouver la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro du 7-8 loisir
très bon week-end à tous
[Musique]